discussion on
education and its purpose and meaning
and its place in a free republic
and we are here with the great secretary
of education
elizabeth devos a wonderful person
thank you for coming secretary pleasure
to be here
thanks dr and uh if you kids can
remember your names perhaps you would
introduce yourselves
i'm jonah apple uh i graduated from a
bcsi school last year
and i am going to major in politics here
at hillsdale
he's a freshman i'm natasha de virgilio
i'm a senior here studying politics i
also graduated from a bcsi school
the same one as jonah my name is
kathleen o'toole i'm the assistant
provost for k-12 education here at
hillsdale college
that means i oversee the bcsi the barney
charter school initiative
and hillsdale academy i started the
school that these two
brilliant kiddos went to
mr whitey well i'm ben whitey
i'm a senior here studying biochemistry
and i am
a part of the classical education minor
i'm grace shanely i'm a senior studying
english and also
a classical education minor i plan on
teaching next year
yeah i'm dan copeland and i'm a
professor of education
and i'm the chairman of the education
department here at hillsdale college
i teach courses um on
english grammar in classic children's
literature and
these two are are my students
i'm david whalen associate vice
president for curriculum
and a professor of english
thank you so i'm going to ask some
questions
and i may direct them to somebody and i
may not but all of you feel free to pipe
in when you want to
i'll direct the first one to dan what do
we mean by classical education
well um it's a term that's thrown around
and
if you if you google it online you will
see i mean a wide variety of definitions
but typically most of the definitions
that have to do with
classical education include at least two
elements
and that's wisdom and virtue
which are critically important because
it speaks to
the idea that it's not just about
filling students heads
with facts it's about
helping to instill knowledge and
ultimately wisdom
and an understanding of the world in a
wide variety of
capacities and so knowing things is
important
in the field that in any field in
history
literature in the sciences and the
mathematics we need to know things and
schools should be about that
it should be about communicating things
so wisdom the cultivation of wisdom
but classical education does not just
leave it leave education with the head
it's also concerned with the heart as
well
and classical education is about the
cultivation of virtue
of character of morality and it's not
just about
helping to to cultivate smart
human beings they're not truly human
beings if their character has not been
has not been cultivated they're not
fully human
until they have both the wisdom and the
virtue
what makes classical education special
is that it's grounded
in a tradition a long-standing tradition
what classical education is not it's not
a fad
it's not something new that suddenly all
these schools are opening up
um with the next new technique in the
field of education it's old
i mean it's thousands of years old so
you know those of us who are involved in
classical education are trying to tap
into
a tradition and we're trying
to promote that bring it back because we
think
that the cultivation of wisdom and
virtue is worthwhile
thank you uh natasha what is wisdom
wisdom is
with the aristotelian definition it's an
intellectual virtue
and it's the highest one um and the kind
of short way that we like to phrase it
is
it's you know you have wisdom when you
have knowledge of the things that don't
change
the permanent things
not bad is she secretary devos you may
speak up or ask a question whenever he
please of course
um mr april why
why is education important in a
republican form of government and what
is that form
well if you're asking what is the
republican form of government i think
first and foremost it involves both a
rule of the people
and self-governments so whenever there's
whenever you govern yourself right it
requires that virtue that
uh dr copeland's been talking about um
you have to
you have to understand both like what
what really matters
and you have to be cultivated into a
habit of
doing those things because in
self-government
the you know cornerstone of a republic
involves
action not just like understanding and
so
in the article in conception you have to
habituate yourself towards virtue
and so that's kind of the first and
foremost step of education
in a republic and then i guess the other
thing is that the republic
it's not you know be there is
self-government
involved in it but it's not simply a
rule of the majority
you then have to say okay well
how can the majority of the people rule
towards the common good of everyone
because aristotle
and then the founders later who you know
inform our
american form of government they're
worried about
you know the rule of the majority
because if those people haven't been
cultivated by education to wisdom and
virtue
then they might pass laws and things
like that
that bring harm to their own citizens
and so i think ultimately there
you have to understand how to
how to have a care and concern for
others in that form of government in
that self-rule
so that therefore like the
so the rule of people doesn't become
corrupted so the rule of the people
ends in the common happiness of all and
not
to the rule of one majority over
an an oppressed either minority or a
majority
anybody anything to that
you're going to get your chance
grace there's unrest on college campuses
why do you think that is and does it
have to do with the excuse me i can't
keep my mask out of my mouth
uh does it have to do with what they
study in the colleges do you think as
far as you know
well dr arn i've thought about this a
lot
um this summer especially because i was
at home
with friends who go to different sorts
of colleges than hillsdale
like big state universities
and i found that oftentimes the
passion the the overwhelming
anger fear frustration
that my peers are experiencing can come
from
a lack of perspective
a lack of trust and
a lack of a sense of the bigger picture
that i do think my classical education
has prepared me to look at history
look at man's failings
with more hope
and with more trust that with wisdom and
with the practice of virtue
even if it comes in the smallest actions
that that's where change begins with
trust
in history and trust in
a balanced education so
i do think there is something to be said
for classical education as a tempering
influence
on the passion of youth that seeks
naturally to reform and to bring good
into situations which is a very good
inclination
but can sometimes go awry especially in
large groups that are just
bursting with emotion
dr r may i jump in yes it's
it's also worth pointing out perhaps
that
uh commonplace in contemporary
university college and university
education
is that the purpose of that education
is what is now called activism
that is the unrest on the campuses in
part answers to what the students have
been told
the very function and purpose of their
education happens to be
turning from thoughtless citizens
perhaps to
something we we call an activist now the
object or goal
purpose the end of the action
is never clearly defined usually you get
vague formulations like uh social
uh reformation justice or or
um modification of the of the uh
of the culture in some ill-defined way
this is in contrast to every
prior understanding of post-secondary
education has
still fundamentally a place of learning
what one does depends upon
what is and we have to learn what things
are before we can learn
how to interact with them or respond to
them
that kind of learning has been shoved
aside in favor of a kind of
hasty urgent even restless so-called
activism
it's a view to the good of the student
how do we understand
the relationship between public
education and the family
what do we think about that dan what do
you think about that then i'll ask mr
whitey
yeah well i think um it it's important
to view
you know parents as as the first
and often the best educators um
and i think it's important that they're
involved
in the decisions that go into
schooling for their own children they
know their children the best
they know what they need um but they
also have the most at stake
i mean they're their kids right
but that said we as a society should do
what we can to provide
resources so that parents can be
successful
and one way to do that is to provide
schooling and i think that we should
view schooling teachers
as a resource to parents in trying to
help them to do the things that maybe
they're
not well equipped to do
but all with the idea in mind
that ultimately we're serving the family
and it's not anything benjamin
um as someone who went to a public
school myself
i would say that there is there is great
value in having public education it's
something that
um the way that our society runs today
it's
it's a necessity because not everyone
can stay home and educate their children
um and with that in mind i agree with
what dr copeland has said like
the the idea the purpose of the school
is to serve the family in
creating and developing uh individuals
who are
competent responsible tempered
but i think it also falls
to the parents to develop those virtues
in their own children to supplement the
education that the public
that the public school can give because
they can't do everything
our parents regarded in the charter
schools dr
well i think that charter schools are
particularly
this is particularly prevalent in
charter schools because by definition if
you
are sending your child to a charter
school you are choosing that school
for your child and speaking as someone
who's run one of these schools that's a
great
that's a great gift it's a great gift to
know that the children are there because
their parents wanted them to be there
it's also it also means something about
the relationship between the parent and
the school
it means that the parent has has
recognized that the parent has the
responsibility
of choosing something that will be good
for the child and that the school
owes the parent accurate information
about
what is going to be taught at that
school i remember when we first started
our school in leander
it was uh you know i got up there in
front of a bunch of parents and i was
giving a talk about
the curriculum and i said my job is to
explain to you
what happens at this school so that you
can decide
if it's right for your children
and they had never these particular
parents had never received a talk of
that type
from a school administrator they had
always been held at arm's length
by the school they were allowed to ask
certain questions regarding
health and safety but no one had ever
really taken the time to explain what
books
are their children going to learn uh and
so it
that began the process project of sort
of changing the culture among the
parents
and helping them learn that not only was
it okay to ask questions they ought to
ask questions
and teaching them what kinds of
questions they ought to be asking
and i think that in the end they made
they made the school stronger because of
it
it's a good thing for the school when
the parents are ready to
hold the school accountable
what's parents weekend like here david
parents weekend is a
barely controlled two-day party
[Laughter]
where where the parents ostensibly here
to
inquire after the the uh welfare not
just health and welfare
but the intellectual and academic
welfare of their children
actually enjoy talking to each other
meeting each other and treat it as a
kind of reunion that happens twice a
year
so joking aside uh parents weekends are
common
on campuses across the country but
they're usually
fairly tame events here they're not
out of control but they are occasions
where the parents
actually sit and meet and speak with the
faculty
that semester teaching the parents
sons and daughters it's not
you might think oh so it's a
continuation of high school
parent-teacher conferences
that would only be true superficially
the parents know
that the students here are engaged in
an extraordinary and it's an overused
word let me avoid cliches
the parents know that their their sons
and daughters are engaged
in life grounding intellectual
and and personal activities here and
they
they want to make sure that the
the faculty understand just how precious
those sons and daughters are
i i have to say that rather than saying
how what are the grades and how are they
doing
they they mostly want to tell you about
their sons and daughters they want to
look in your eye and see if you
recognize that these young men and women
are
beautiful precious beyond belief and
beloved um maybe that sounds too
romantic but i
i after decades of experience here with
parents weekend that's
really how i would know hyperbole that's
how i would characterize it
every year i have uh this year this last
semester i just said two
come up to me and say parents come up to
me and say uh
this is too good for my kid can i come
here
that happens and that happens in class
too that is
a lot of prospective students visit
and sit in on classes and their parents
will accompany them quite often
and almost invariably the parents say
that very thing when they come up after
class to thank you they say
i don't care about my kid can i take
this good but
um they're joking of course but they
the there is an interesting partnership
between the college parents and the
students it's not the kind of thing
where you just drop your kid off and
get out of our face go away we we
want the parents to be attentive we have
to
we require space in which to do our work
of course we can't be interfered with
but the parents aren't extraneous
they're
part of this partnership as well and
it's not just that they appreciate it
they understand that what we're doing is
continuing as dan
suggests we're continuing what they
began
yeah i have a principal that i love to
state
and i thought it up one time reading
something that secretary devos published
the proper sovereign in education is the
school
because it's in the school where the
students and the parents and the
teachers
all of whom know each other do the
actual work that goes on in the school
and so things that are powerful that are
remote from the school
they can't have the information and
that's you know like we're very famous
around here we don't
we don't take kindly to people telling
us what to do
but the reason is this is our problem
right we
are in contact with the enemy i mean the
students every day
so so what do they need
how do you help them and you know we
also can't forget
if you you know in these charter schools
i see it i never saw
understood it fully until i came to work
here but
the students do the learning and it's
hard for them
and if they're not focused on it at
every moment they're not learning
anything so somehow this
idea of bottom-up government that's the
american idea
was especially good for education and
top-down
is the rule in every area of policy now
and i think it's particularly disastrous
in education
and i thank the secretary for resisting
that so effectively
thanks dr
can i ask the students a question yeah
oh you want so i'm really curious i'm
really curious from the students
what drew you to hillsdale college and
sort of as a precursor to that was your
experience
through your k-12 years
similar in preparation or was it a a
good preparation
for the type of approach and study that
you're doing
at hillsdale currently whoever wants to
start
okay benjamin you're getting off easy
yeah i'll jump in
um uh i came to hillsdale
um because i visited twice once
by myself and once for the scholars
weekend that they do here
and i was blown away by the amount
of community and the closeness of that
community
that exists here um it's a very small
school
use i see the same people every day and
that's something that
i had at my um at my public high school
it was about 800
kids and i really liked that and the
in addition to that community was also
the faculty
the faculty that we have here are
amazing
and that's that's no extension um
no hyperbole and that was
that was really exciting to to see that
relative to the other schools that i had
visited
right so was this sort of an extension
of your experience in high school
certainly in terms of size but uh
in pr in in terms of its approach to uh
learning and expectations and
uh in terms of size yes in terms of
style
not so much i went to i went to a very
good public high school but
like i said the community is totally
different and the
um a lot of the teachers did have a
similar similar passion for teaching
passion for the students
and they were those teachers with ones
that actually pointed me to hillsdale
because they knew that i would like it
and they they cared
so but the the rigor the academic rigor
is something that
i was unprepared for and happily
challenged by
that first semester was a little
challenging probably
it was a little bit of a culture shock
but it was uh i've come to
enjoy it the average high school gpa
coming in here is 3.92 and the average
freshman
gpa is 2.85
we call that chart shock and awe
i'm ready i can go next i
went to private catholic school
in elementary and middle and high school
and even though they weren't classical
schools
i found there that
the fire was lit within me because
the liturgical sacramental
context that i learned everything in
very much
taught the discipline and the love
that made me seek out a classical
liberal arts college so i looked at
all catholic colleges and hillsdale was
the only
college that i looked at that was not
catholic
but when i came and visited here
when i met the students i came on
scholars weekend too
and actually that's when i met ben and
we've been friends ever since
when i came here and met the students i
realized that
they would challenge me and that
i had nothing to fear from going to a
college
that wasn't
expressly catholic because the students
here would be
leading me towards the truth so
that's what's happened i've come here
and i've made friends
of all denominations that have
brought me closer to god so that has
been amazing
and it's true the communities here are
so strengthening and
so unique and i'm very sad to leave but
i know
now i know the value of building a
community like that and i hope that
wherever i go
i can bring that spirit with me
that's great thank you grace
um going to a barney charter school i a
lot of my teachers were hillsdale grads
but i would say i was having such a good
time there that i really didn't spend a
lot of time
thinking about what i was supposed to do
after
graduation so sure enough senior year
rolls around and i find that
i don't know what it means to go to
college i was always a good student and
so it kind of and i wanted to keep
studying so it
seemed to make sense like maybe keep
studying go to college
um but i did some college visits and i i
just felt like no one was really
explaining to me what it meant to go to
college i'm the oldest in my family
i didn't have very many friends or
family members who were college students
and i would go on these tours of
colleges where they would point out all
the great amenities
like here's our state of the art sports
facility here are
newly updated dorms and that was great
but i kind of walked away thinking like
do you guys do class here
but i so i was
in my senior year had no idea what i was
doing and
i kind of had a gang of teachers who
really cared about me
talk me into applying to hillsdale
which for some reason i just never
considered
they were like hey you you say you like
to study
you're really interested in a place
where they're going to take texts
seriously and where professors are going
to engage with you and care about you
and the other students will care that
much as well
if you want the kind of experience that
you've been enjoying here maybe you
should be going to hillsdale
somehow those two pieces didn't click
together in my brain
but when people who cared about me were
helping me see that
i kind of thought that that would be a
good idea
um then there was a little bit more
pressure involved from
from other actors
let's say i got involved at some point
and that was pretty direct
don't know you want to add something
yeah i mean so for me
again going to that same barney charter
school i think the things that i was
learning i i recognized that they were
they were good for me not just in terms
of like knowing them
but they were really good for my
character and for my soul and
going to the founders for four years
just seeing how much it had my education
and the community surrounding the
education everyone learning the same
things
that are of such value reading the same
great texts
having great conversations seeing how
that transformed me as a as a person
um really just led me to
to really learn long for for more of
that
and so i think going here for me was
just
the the obvious next step in my journey
to to really grow as a person to feed my
soul
in a sense and so studying these
these things of such great importance um
yeah and in community with some of the
best teachers in the world i think was
really just what
led me to do it to come here to continue
studying
um and in particular to
to study kind of politics and the
philosophy of
politics that's you know what i'm going
to major in um
reading those things makes you think
about not just
you know a particular my new field of
study
but about kind of the universal
the universal things that that are
really good for an education of
anyone it's in a sense it's a universal
education and it's an education
not unique to any kind of particular
person but an education that's good for
everyone and so studying studying the
things that
you know wanted that i thought were just
really important
to to not only like know on a surface
level but to know deeply
such that they're ingrained in my soul
is
just very important to me and so that
that really led me to
pursue hillsdale and i'm really enjoying
my time here so far
and i think it's doing a lot for me
awesome thanks jonah
dr could i ask you what was the
motivation
for actually launching the charter
school initiative
well of course lots and lots of people
are very concerned about what's going on
in education in the country
and a lot of those people would poke me
in the chest and say
you have to do something about k through
12 education
you know and uh the first opportunity
that was milton friedman
the great economist uh and then uh
somebody you probably knew john walton
of the walton family who was killed in a
plane crash
two months after i sent him a letter and
told him what i thought i could do
and what could we do you know first of
all we're not
you know campaign organization for
school reform
you know or initiatives so if we know
anything we know how to teach
and so the great barrier and i said we
should help schools get better
we should know how to do that and the
great barrier was
colleges start charter schools often and
they get some revenue from it
and we don't take that money so we don't
get that
and uh but then then i got to thinking
more we couldn't really even own a
charter school
uh so we uh
i started talking to people and uh
people i know that i respect and i'd say
why don't you start a charter school
we'll help you
and then sure enough citizens you know
there are 25 of them they're going to be
we don't know how many but there's three
four years the way it's running
and those are chances for
self-government for
the people who form those schools and
they don't any of them get paid for it
and we don't make any money from it and
the school is funded by
usually about 75 of what the public
schools
get and in most cases that's plenty you
can do it with that
so yeah that was the idea and
i got partial to it and then dan
copeland down there and
david whalen there has taught me a lot
of what i know about education
but what could we contribute
and if we can contribute something it's
knowledge of the fundamentals
of education things that are abiding in
education
whatever else is going on in the economy
in the world
every kid is a human being they need to
find out what they need to know to live
a good life
and those take attributes of character
and intellect
so education from plato's academy to
today
has always been concerned chiefly with
those things
so we try to bring that focus now that's
how it got started and
steve barney is a it's called the barney
charter school that's because steve
barney
he's got a great he's a trustee of the
college now he has a great gift
he gets emotional and cries about things
he's a big blubber baby
and we were at his house in florida
and he's especially bad about poking me
in the chest he said do you know
two blocks from here there's a school
full of poor kids
and they're not learning anything the
numbers are you
have to do something about that and i
said to say i said to him
you know i thought of something and the
next thing you know we got the barney
project
that's how it got going um
and um there's nobody waiting to get
into these schools
it's uh yeah i think they're last
numbers what are the numbers katie
uh last counting there's 6 000 people
waiting to get on the
waiting to get into these schools but
the number is in fact much higher than
that
and changing all the time it's very
common for these schools to open up and
not to have enough seats for all the
people who want to go
and the schools are difficult too by the
way you know
there's an honor code you gotta
everybody learns latin
in these schools and they flock to it
yeah and if i may there's there's
something
there's something beautiful about that
and there's something unexpected about
that
you know sometimes when people hear
natasha and jonah and grace and ben
speak
they think classical education is for
the really
academic kids you know for the kids who
just love school and have the high test
scores
but these charter schools are just for
everyone and all of the kids come
and they all learn latin and unless
there's
a rare reason why they cannot such as a
learning disability or something they
all learn to translate latin
by the time they're in ninth grade they
read the eliot they read shakespeare
they give a senior thesis before they
graduate every single last one of them
and so i think that shows that classical
education is american education
it's not it's not one select method of
doing it it's
the way of doing it that that our
country needs and
in many places used to have
kids today learned that thomas jefferson
was author of the declaration of
independence and he was a slave holder
what they don't learn is he was deeply
troubled about that all his life and
wrote beautiful things about the wrong
of it
and he is the prime reason there's never
been slavery in the northwest territory
which includes michigan because the land
came as a gift from virginia to the
union
thomas jefferson was the mover of that
he insisted that there be a clause and
it's there in the northwest ordinance
that there will never be slavery here
now if kids learn all of that
it produces something in them it
produces more respect for thomas
jefferson
while admitting the fault but in
addition
it teaches them to look at the past and
see things are never perfect
maybe they can be great but they're not
perfect
and and and we can't look back on the
past smugly
and say we're so much better than they
are
it gives a motive to work and to learn
and to try then to read lead a lit a
rich and excellent life
which is hard to do
david i have a question is it all right
i have a question for you and then we're
going to have to stop
how do you decide what should be in a
curriculum in a college or school
well first you assemble a committee
okay see the fact that there was
laughter
is an index of just how poisonously
wrong that answer is
the in a way dr copeland
touched on the central point in in his
earlier remarks
a curriculum is not a political
compromise of competing interests
i should say ideally properly a
curriculum is not
a
compromise of competing interests rather
it's an answer to the question what does
every educated
man and woman need to know
about things that are universally
important
and and what what dan said
is that the rich
tradition of learning uh that we've all
inherited
we often throw away our inheritance but
we've all inherited
a uh at least the the access to
a rich tradition of learning about
what kinds of things promote wisdom what
kinds of things are conducive to virtue
what kinds of threats and dangers and
obstacles are there to our intellectual
apprehension our moral correction
it's it's uh there's a wealth
of of um good and bad to learn about in
the world
and the literary cultural historical
political tradition
uh that we've all been born into can
teach us a lot about that
and so you have recourse to that
tradition
in pursuit of the answer to the question
i asked just a moment ago what does
every educated man or woman need to know
and and what that usually turns into is
uh a set of principles
they don't you you don't need to learn
everything
about physics or history you don't need
to
cram your mind with endless uh uh
streams of minutiae what you really need
you need
lots of information you do have to
ground everything
that you learn in in
[Music]
truths facts things that that you can
really wrap your mind
around but what you're aiming for are
principles
principles that apply even to the things
you haven't learned yet
so maybe that's too vague or abstract an
answer but i guess in brief i would say
a curriculum is not just a keeping
together of whatever you have at hand
and i'm afraid that's what it all too
often is maybe my
view is too jaundiced but instead a
curriculum
looks at the bodies of learning
available to us
especially those time tested
and inherited and discerns in that body
of learning
what it is that we need to pass on to
the next generation that can help them
lead the kind of life you just described
you had anything secretary no i think
that was a really thoughtful and
deep explanation for what is a very
complex
topic and one that has lots and lots of
opinions surrounding it but
i think you i think you really
articulated it well thank you
i think that's also a good place to stop
and it's time to stop
and so we'll see most of you at dinner i
think thank you secretary of education
betsy devos